hey everyone meet boat Jared here season
3 episode 7 of Rick and Morty is one of
the darkest and densest of the season in
less than half an hour the episode
manages to build a rich complex and
utterly dismal political world only for
the show to summarily dismiss it still
not curious about what might have
happened at that crazy Citadel place not
at all Morty that place will never have
any bearing over our lives ever again
but in that short time the Rick Lantis
mix-up paints a really interesting
picture of modern politics specifically
as it pertains to hope resistance and
revolution welcome this wisecrack quick
take on the Rick lantus mix-up and you
guessed it spoilers ahead but before we
get into that I want to thank kwid for
sponsoring this video
Quaid is a really cool app that allows
you to collect stickers cards and toys
for free featuring a bunch of the shows
we love here at wisecrack Breaking Bad
Adventure Time Bob's Burgers Star Trek
and most importantly Rick and Morty
think about it like opening up packs of
baseball cards
I've actually been collecting Rick and
Morty stickers for about a month now and
it's actually amazing how quick they are
to add new stickers pretty much the day
after a new episode is released they
have new gifts and stickers that you can
send your friends over text or slap onto
images in your camera roll my favorite
is the mailman from M night Shyamalan
that says mom man check out the
description below for a link to grab the
app for free it's available on iOS and
Android I'm on there as Jared c-137
last time we did this for us 600 of you
added me as a friend and we had some
cool chats and trades with some of you
so add me as a friend and trade me all
your meeseeks swag thanks a bunch
back to the show so a quick recap Rick
and Morty go on an adventure to Atlantis
but don't worry
that actually doesn't matter instead
we're thrown into the Citadel of Rick's
as they rebuild after the catastrophic
events of the Rick shank redemption
democratic elections are being held for
the first time in the wake of the
dissolution of the council Rick's
the world-building in this episode is
freaking amazing especially in how it
cleverly mirrors our current political
climate from a news organization that's
only one and away from CNN that
trivializes descent in order to maintain
the status quo anyway so yeah the
suspect says the citadel is a lie built
on lies and some others I say appreciate
the life you have because it can always
be worse to an inner city devastated by
drugs and guns to a Hogwarts that
teaches the disenfranchised more teased
to accept their lot this is a great
adventure this is definitely one of the
harder narratives to follow and
certainly more complex than your
traditional episode so I want to lay out
the many subplots as follows
evil Morty comes to power on a platform
of unity and change before revealing his
grander and more totalitarian intentions
in an allusion to training day a fresh
out of the Academy police rick has to
join a crooked cop morty and confront
the corrupt underbelly of the citadel
where he is forced to confront his
ideals and abandon them it seems
reminiscent of the ending of LA
Confidential where an idealistic cop has
to break the rules and kill his superior
undermining the same justice system he
thought he was protecting a group of
orphaned Morty's set off for an
adventure a la stand by me before
sending their hopes and dreams into the
literal trash
a Rick is passed over for a promotion
and realizes he's wasted his life on an
assembly line he revolts but his triumph
is quickly ruined by the powers that be
in all of these cases we see any kind of
political or personal optimism for
change crushed by a cruel and
indifferent reality this episode really
builds off the themes that we talked
about earlier in Rick man Singh the
stone specifically alienation or the way
modern society estranges us from the
world in our peers making us all dead
inside in the case of Rick man Singh the
stone the creature comforts of society
turn the exciting world of the
apocalypse into a domestic nightmare
now we see many versions of the smartest
man in the universe reduced to the
drudgery of modern life and mixed in we
see signs of a deeply divided society
the number of displaced Morty's is
soaring while Rick's satisfaction levels
are plummeting and the divide between
the two groups has never been whiter
solve that one real quick but as evil
Morty suggests this is a distraction
outrage is the Rick's and Morty's
feeding on the Citadel's dead the real
divide the rich versus the working-class
I don't see a divide between Rick's and
Morty's the division I see is between
the Rick's and Morty's that like the
Citadel divided and the rest of us
what's interesting is that despite the
apparent ruling class of Rick's everyone
is a victim of alienation you didn't
come to the Citadel to be a plumber did
you even the cops are likened to just
workers on the assembly line of justice
but in addition to being victims of
those individuals in power the Rick's
are also victims of an impenetrable
system and here's where my favorite part
of the whole episode comes in his name
is simple Rick but he's no dummy he
realized long ago that the greatest
thing he'd ever create was his daughter
we captured that moment we run it on a
loop through simple Rick's mind and the
chemical that makes his brain secrete
goes into every simple Rick's simple
wafers wafer cookie come home
to the impossible flavor of your own
completion come home to simple rigs this
gets at a really smart question tackled
by a lot of different philosophers but
I'll summarize the issue as this is our
escape from the alienation of modern
life just strengthening the foundations
of the system that drives that
alienation simple Rick follows what I'll
call the Ron Swanson trope someone who
fights our fast-paced world by slowing
down working with their hands and
spending time with the family in a world
that crams us into cubicles and hunches
us over assembly lines our only respite
is the simple life running away from the
urban clamor living off the land
learning a trade like woodworking
reconnecting with your family etc not
surprisingly this kind of idea gained
prevalence as the world was
industrialized and subsequently
corporatized we saw the rise of
organizations like the Boy Scouts and
the establishment of national parks
where you could practice not being
crammed in a city but it could be argued
that this escape to the simple life
whether in the form of nature or family
or woodworking is not in fact retreating
from the system but an essential part of
its functioning we can view these simple
Rick wafers brand as a kind of fantasy
that reinforces the system
Rick's show up for work because they
know they can go home and allegedly
unplug from the system with the
distilled essence of simplicity even
though this unplugging comes in
commodity form one that requires you
know money that you have to work for at
an assembly line and we've all seen
enough cereal commercials to know that
advertisers love selling us a kind of
pure wholesome family who actually eats
meals together without screaming at each
other sociologists George Ritzer says
that our enchantment with and
disenchantment from the modern world are
not so easy to distinguish from each
other
he says they exist in a reciprocal
relation in other words the fantasy of
unplugging with some simple Rick wafers
further entrenches you in the very
system you want to unplug from but it
gets even more devious as one Rick
decides he's had enough and engages an
actual act of rebellion killing his boss
and trying to get a portal gun to
actually escape the system but instead
of effecting change his rebellion is
commodify
right in the form of the simple Rick
freedom wafer selects come home to the
unique flavor of shattering the grand
illusion he endlessly lives the joy of
rebellion while the system distills this
joy in a consumable form free them from
the system entraps you in the system
Ritzer goes on to say that fantasies
draw people into the new means of
consumption and those fantasies can be
rationalized in order to further draw
people in and this for me makes this the
darkest episode of the season yet the
message seems to be in the terrifying
political reality that is 2017 the best
we can hope for is the illusion of
making a difference if you don't believe
me remember the orphan Morty's plot they
go on a coming-of-age adventure trying
to escape their terrible orphan
existence and their bondage to some
future Rick but the wish portal turns
out to be a garbage portal the system
turns wishes into literal trash Slick
Morty sacrifices himself to wish for a
better world and it happened sort of
holy crap slicks wish came true I don't
think we're meant to believe that his
sacrifice magically made things better
especially because the change promise
was just a ploy by evil Morty the
subplot has no actual bearing on the
overall narrative it only seems to exist
for the writers to show us the naive
ideas of these children that slick morty
sacrifice could have changed something
nothing they did mattered but they get
to believe it did
just like our revolting Rick so what do
we make of evil Morty he sold a kind of
class consciousness to the Rick's and
Morty's of the Citadel that bricks and
more used to join together to make a
better world against the ruling elite
but with the brutal purge of his
political opponents it seems like this
was nothing more than lip service as a
means to power but hey could we really
expect any kind of real progress from
this show there's just so much going on
in this episode that we haven't touched
on like is there some connection between
this Latin phrase on the chalkboard and
evil Morty's view of how society
functions we'll discuss this as well as
dive into the show's commentary on the
media state violence and who really
controls the government on the Squatch
wisecracks Rick and Morty podcast check
out on iTunes stitcher google play or
were
you get your podcast the link is in the
description and don't forget to
subscribe well beloved of W all peace